[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you
eating ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony em
[Music]
the party of the face plant
steps on rates
in New York City of course they do not a
surprise why should this be surprising
that Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan
is a professional rake stepper
you know you think they would have
learned from their little border hearing
that they had their little field trip
border hearing that they had that it's
not advisable
to go to different parts of the country
and try to politicize and weaponize the
house Judiciary Committee which Jim
Jordan is doing today and his goal is to
obstruct Alvin Bragg's criminal
investigation
that he took to a grand jury in the
grand jury voted
to indict Donald Trump on 34 felony
charges of business fraud
it's not complicated stuff to understand
hmm
is there um
maybe the sound is messed up is the
sound okay because people are saying the
sound might be might be gone is it can
you hear me out there tell me if you can
hear me
so
Jim Jordan decides a kangaroo court is
the most appropriate thing
in New York
New York did not uh welcome them well
and we're going to watch
uh several clips of this great everyone
says they can hear me fantastic
so
Jim Jordan with this Kangaroo Court was
not prepared for Democrats to I don't
know bring up gun violence
as most Americans are concerned with gun
violence on
Saturday
we had nine mass shootings nine nine
mass shootings
are you are you kidding me
there are there are civilized Western
countries in this world who don't have
nine mass shootings in the last 20 years
and the reason why folks is the guns
it's the guns it's the guns it's the
guns
it's the guns you dumb and
Democrats this morning
in this Kangaroo Court this
weaponization of the Judiciary Committee
that Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan
has gone to New York City to obstruct
the Manhattan D.A Alvin Bragg's felony
case 34 felonies to be exact into Donald
J Trump
wants to make it about crime in New York
City
you know the crime in Ohio is like 10
times that of New York City
you know there's a lot of folks in New
York City I don't know if you know this
I don't know if Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan knows this I don't know if
the Republicans know this I don't know
if this is the first time they've been
to New York City
are done any kind of their own research
into the city of New York but it's a big
and there's a lot of people
there there's a high population inside
the city
and per capita they have one of the
lowest crime rates of City all around
the nation it's one of the safest cities
to go to now that wasn't the truth in
the 1970s and 80s
but it's become true today
and almost any major city in the United
States is way safer way less crime per
capita than any
of these Republicans districts
mark my words mark my words
Americans are on to Republicans
and the more they capitulate
to American fascism this trumpism mocha
the worse it's going to get for
them
trust me
don't doubt me trust me
it's going to happen
and the rake stepping will continue
they'll continue to face plant they'll
continue to run straight into the point
face first and not get it listen there
is a a lot of protest in Kansas City
this morning
in my home state
of Kansas City 16 year old boy
goes to pick up his brother at a
friend's house
he arrives at his friend's house
unbeknownst to him it's not the correct
residence he knocks on the door like a
polite person would to pick up a person
that they know at someone else's house
that they don't know he was shot in the
head twice
and shot again on the porch once
by a white man
the young man the 16 year old boy
he's a child
but in
America
in the white gun culture of America
this young man
came to the wrong porch while black
no threat posed other than the color of
his skin and the weakness behind the gun
but there was a gun folks it's it's the
guns
you know I told you last week that we
must move the goal post it's time we
move the goal post on guns no more oh do
something no more red flags or
background checks we are coming for your
guns gun nuts 2A bros we're
coming for your guns this country is not
gonna put up with this
I I know it feels like oh nothing ever
happens that talk talking talk talk and
nothing ever happens folks
gun violence
is compounding
it's not St it's not gotten worse and
staying the same it's getting worse
every moment that we don't do anything
and we should be moving the goal post
and we should be telling two ebros and
gun nuts out there hey you know those
red flag Lawns if you're against Common
Sense gun reform like background checks
and red black logs we'll take your
guns you're the problem you you
you're the problem if you're against
these things you don't get to have guns
sensible I think that's sensible if you
if you dispouse any kind of a rhetoric
online on your social media it's your
right to say that stuff you have the
freedom speak
your mind
about guns in the Second Amendment but
the moment you do we get to Red Flag
your dumb ass
and not only do we red flag you from
having or going to buy guns we take your
guns it's enough of this
take them and melt them down publicly
I think what we should do is melt down
gun nuts guns
and turn them into nice little pieces of
Art
maybe what we should do is turn them
into NRA Maga tears that's what we
should do you know nice little statues
or or mementos that people could put on
their bookshelves well not bookshelves
they don't have books they want to get
rid of the books too they want
to ban drag shows ban books ban the
lgbtq community
but guns oh boy that's just that's just
an infringible right you can go to
hell you can go to hell you
bastards
infringe on rights
what about the young man who got
shot in the face
on the porch for knocking on the wrong
door
the young man went to the 1100 block of
115th Northeast Terrace and he was
supposed to go to Northeast Street
he got one word wrong
and some white man decided it was his
prerogative to kill that young man
because he was standing on his porch
while black
you proved me wrong
go for it try it I dare you in the
meantime the authorities just let this
out back on the streets
there should be no peace for this son of
a absolutely no peace there should
be absolute protests that
shouldn't even be able to leave his
house without hearing protest of crowds
screaming that he's a murderer
and a racist you goddamn right that's
what I'm saying move the goal post let's
use our voices let's use our microphones
God damn it
it's enough of this we
do not have to put up with this stuff in
this country we are the government we
are the people we get to decide what is
regulated and what is not and what is
reasonable and what is not and any
out there having a gun with
no background check no permit no nothing
is not reasonable it's just not
and we shouldn't put up with it anymore
our children's lives are at stake our
friends our family our community members
our children that God damn our our
children the children's lives
are at stake in Alabama at a sweet 16
party four dead 28 injured
when will it end
it's blood Money Republicans it's
blood money you dumb sons of
and all for what all for what to benefit
a handful of families in this
country who manufacture weapons the
out of here with that
give me a break and you want to
go to New York City you you stupid
want to go to New York
City
to talk about violence and crime in New
York City as if you're doing something
on the Judiciary Committee so you can
obstruct Alvin Bragg's legitimate grand
jury indictment of Donald Trump because
you are a snowflake
huh
that's what that's what you're gonna do
with your power
to help one constituent one Donald Trump
well we know Jim Jordan always looks the
other way
when people he's responsible for
being assaulted
so by God why should we be surprised
that Jim Jordan looks the other way of
gun violence to only protect Donald
Trump in New York City the out of
here with this nonsense we see what
you're doing
we know what the hell's going on
it's obvious
and we know what's going on in this
country with people being murdered in
Banks
and churches in elementary schools
at private venues for sweet 16 parties
hospitals
Office Buildings
beaches you stupid
listen to a Bros listen up listen up if
you think guns are cool
yeah I'm talking to you if you think
guns are cool
and you want to have your guns
you better start changing your mind
about how they can be regulated like
really fast really fast
because as this continues Americans are
not going to put up with this and
trust me when one of their one of their
families friends or community members is
either killed or injured or damned or
damn near killed
I'm telling you
you're gonna regret not getting to the
table and negotiating
you're gonna regret it because at this
point we absolutely should not invite
the NRA the gun lobby or gun
manufacturings to the table to talk
about common sense gun safety not at all
them they done that day has passed
you do not get to participate
in the debate anymore about guns in this
country and that goes to the NRA the gun
lobbyists and the gun manufacturers you
can kick rocks
we do not have to negotiate with you
anymore we don't we're the government
we're the people we elect our
representatives of the Republic and we
do not have to negotiate with you
anymore we just don't you you can
bounce
so two a Bros the people out there that
love their guns and think they're cool
and they want to own a gun
you better wise up fast
quick and in a hurry I'm telling you you
just doubt me on this of where
the country's headed with this
the country is going to take away your
guns they're gonna do it you
keep saying oh Obama's gonna take your
guns Biden's gonna take no we are going
to take your guns We the People
we the people are gonna take away your
gun not just their right to buy
them
we're gonna come get your
it's enough of this stuff
Americans aren't going
to be out and about being terrified
that that some anybody crazy
can grab a gun and start
killing
we're sick of it we're tired of it
and Jim Jordan
Jim Jordan is he's gotta be he's got to
be one of the stupidest son of a
I've ever seen to hold the house seat
and this and this is the
chair of the Judiciary Committee
doesn't even hold a valid
law license he's not even in the bar
and he decides to take a field trip to
one of the safest cities in the
country
and the one of the reasons why it's one
of the safest cities in the
countries because you can't carry a gun
there you can't buy a gun there
you stupid
why do you think
it's safe
all the gun violence is there is is guns
that come from other places
you stupid
and they only gave the opportunity for
Democrats to point this out
which again again folks
is the reason why you need to use your
microphone and I say we need to move the
goal post on this gun debate it should
we should not be chanting do it do
something no take their guns that's
what we should be chanting take their
guns take their guns take their guns
let's start the debate there
that's where we start the negotiations
on these guns from now on them
them em em
you don't like it good
good
that's where we start the debate that's
where we start the negotiations we're
taking your guns we're taking
them and we're gonna melt them down and
we're gonna make nice little
nice little statues for you of Maga and
NRA tears to put on your goddamn on your
bookshelves if you have them
because you took all the books off and
burned them
or put it on your mantle you
goddamn two-way snowflakes
enough of this garbage
I'm sick of it and I know America's sick
of it
take their guns take their guns
take their guns let's do it I'm telling
you move the goal post
it works it works
no more nonsense no more no
more soft lovingness no more of this oh
well I'm not against people having guns
but nope just move the goal post all the
way to the other side of the
field them em em em
them and if you're out there and
you're a liberal and you're like well
Tony I like guns and I own guns tough
tough man that's just
the way it's gonna be let's move the
goal post all the way down to the other
end of the field and let's start there
let's see how they like that
and if these politicians won't
get on board we'll make them get on
board
we got we got primaries coming up folks
we got we got Democratic primaries for
state legislators
for house Democrats
if you start chanting take their guns
take their guns take their guns
I'm telling you I'm telling you I know
you say oh Tony this is this is going to
be worse than defund the police
if you think the country if you think
the country isn't ready to do something
on guns you're out of your mind
out of your mind
tell me tell me you haven't went to an
event somewhere
and the thought crossed your mind
and the thought crossed your mind oh man
let's see
if someone comes in here and starts
shooting where am I going to run to you
where am I you think about it all the
time no matter where you're going it's
going to get worse and worse and worse
and worse and worse
fools hardening churches in garage door
East on schools
where does it end
where does it end because you
you got a hard on for a goddamn
gun get the out of here we do not
have to placate to your sexual ambition
of firearms we don't have to do it in
this country we just don't
we just don't have to
they aren't that cool they aren't that
fun they're not
go do something else go bungee jump with
that Accord you two way Bros that's
really fun I hear I don't know I'm just
saying bungee jumping without a cord is
a hell of an exciting thrill Maga just
throwing that out there I mean it's
almost like firing a
a fully automatic weapon bungee jumping
without a cord that is exhilarating
oh you know what we should do
we should act like we're gonna cancel
bungee jumping
right
and maybe more of them will be like
that you're gonna cancel bungee jumping
or we're gonna go bungee jump like a
oh yeah
let's do that let's do that
hell I got a special guest for you uh
today and I believe she's going to talk
about gun violence is she going to talk
about a lot of things last week
she was brought up in the chat we had
her on a couple weeks ago Jess Piper
Piper for Missouri is here today at the
bottom of the hour so he's going to be
joining us in just a few minutes Jess
Piper I'm super excited to have Jess
back to talk to her a little bit and
then when Gabe Sanchez comes in we're
gonna watch the newest edition of what
was that here on the Tony Michaels
podcast I also want to thank everyone
who joined me last night
who joined me last night on the patreon
party it was so much fun uh thank you
for all the people who asked all the
great questions on the zoom meeting I'm
glad you stuck around and and listened
Jimmy belt out the tune R2
and so thank you very much for joining
us I appreciate all the support you are
the best audience in the entire world
and the very first patreon party I have
to say
I'm not that great at Zoom
um I don't deal with zoom much so I was
having some difficulties but I finally
got it going we finally got it to where
we could have some fun and I made it on
time I always make it on time but I was
having trouble I had to do a few tests
uh before the uh before the party
started but um so I appreciate you guys
staying patient with me last night on
the uh on the party as I tried to figure
out how to use zoom in real time
but I'll tell you that if you guys want
to go watch it
um the first one I made completely
public
um it's it's on the YouTube channel I
changed the title this morning to Tony
Michael's uh patreon party so you can go
check it out and you check out what the
patreon party at least the first one
even even my mess ups I don't care are
my my obvious
um ignorance of Zoom uh is on Full
display so go watch that that's
hilarious probably but we had some great
questions from um the members of patreon
over there they had some great questions
and and I want to tell them all thank
you um because they had very nice things
to say about the show about me about our
hard work here about Gabe's hard work
which we really appreciate and trust me
we do not we we notice that you guys are
here and that you're chatting and that
you love the show we noticed that every
single day and it doesn't go without
appreciation we appreciate all of you
here whether you're on patreon whether
you're watching whether you're sharing
whether you you buy merch or not we love
having you here as part of the chat
family as part of the patreon family as
as part of the YouTube family the
Facebook family the twitch family
everyone over on Twitter we love that
you're part of this of this movement the
em fam and um a lot of people gave
me great words of encouragement last
night and it's only because of you is
the reason why I still do this every
single weekday for two full hours we
want to go to three we're getting there
I promise you we're getting there really
fast as we grow this audience out and we
get more and more people watching last
month in March we had 4.7 million
minutes watched and that was with a
seven day suspension already
sense that suspension I think we have
almost six million minutes viewed
um here on this channel just this
channel alone this YouTube channel the
Tony Michaels podcast so don't forget to
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
here on YouTube you can go check that
video out from the patreon party now we
I sang a little bit of karaoke also
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod and do me a favor do me a favor
because it's free it doesn't cost you a
thing go download every single episode
on Apple's Spotify Google on all of them
it's free over there it helps us out
here at the podcast by you downloading
and listening to the audio version also
follow us on Facebook if you're over
there at Tony Michaels at the Tony
Michaels just uh click the link there
and follow us there also you can find us
broadcasting on the up wires YouTube
channel just go to the upwire.com you
can find their YouTube channel there
there's some great content creators over
on the up wire and they're posting
shorts some videos all the time there's
some more podcasts over there on the up
wire go check it out also if you want to
give me a Billionaire's money let just a
couple bucks of Amazon Jeff bezos's
Money here's what you do if you got an
Amazon Prime account you go and you link
it to a Twitch account and could you get
one free subscription with Amazon Prime
on Twitch one it doesn't cost you a
single nickel it's already included in
your Amazon Prime account and you just
select it you give it to me every month
and you have to do it every month I know
it sounds crazy
it's a lot of work but hey I know you
guys appreciate the show and it's an
easy way for you to give back to the
show and it doesn't cost you a single
nickel just a few minutes each month to
give us that free subscription over on
Twitch so so link your Amazon private
account to Twitch and give us that one
free subscription as I promised
we have a great guest today I think I
think she's you know we have Rachel bit
a confer on all the time we have Texas
Paul every Tuesday
and Jess is in the green room now but
I'm hoping I'm hoping because I know you
guys love her
the audience every time she comes on the
the chat's like
or if any time I bring up her name or a
tweet of hers it just lights up like a
pinball machine so I'm super excited to
have Jess Piper here today and hopefully
we can get her on a couple times a month
to keep us up to date because there's
one thing that she does better than
almost anyone is piss off white male
fragile Republicans it's what I love
most about Jess is she gets in their
Grill and I mean they she is their arch
enemy with just social media it's
Insanity how fragile they are and how
weak they become when when she comments
on their post it is absolutely
chef's kiss delicious so I you know what
I you know I love to bathe in manga
tears but these trumped up fragile white
males are my favorite they're my
favorite especially when they're elected
House Republicans that's right the one
she pisses off the most are elected
House Republicans so don't go anywhere
stick around right after this break Jess
Piper Piper for Missouri we'll be wreck
right after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babble
Mega Edition makes it really easy to
learn and there's lots of lessons to
choose from like subtly racist to
full-blown white supremacist the first
lesson began with learning simple
phrases and soon I was putting those
words and phrases into a conversation
each lesson takes about 10 to 15 minutes
to complete and they're all really
different which keeps things interesting
the app is really smart it actually
keeps track of the word that I'm
struggling with I chose Babble mag
Edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now I can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new Mega skills with my in-laws all
lives matter
thank you
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
yes here's today my request from the
chat last week I think we've brought up
one of her there was a subject that we
brought up you know what it was we were
talking about Mike Moon I believe this
state senator who decided it was a good
idea
to vote for 12 year old girls to get
married Jess Piper thanks for joining us
it is I'm excited to have you back here
on the Tony Michaels podcast thank you
so much how's it going oh it's I you
know I'm fired up this morning it's
Monday morning and as I'm fired up every
single day for democracy I really truly
am I'm excited about
um what is happening in the country on
today with the movements
um there's some sad things that have
happened over the weekend we know in
Kansas City and Missouri a young man was
shot on a front porch uh by apparently
someone who think he has the entitlement
uh with a gun I call it white gun
culture here on the Tony Michaels
podcast where if you have a problem just
you just solve it with a gun and
apparently he had a problem with someone
being on his front porch while black and
a young man is almost had his life taken
away from him and this guy is uh they
have let him go for the time being they
say that they're investigating they're
waiting on a victim statement which
Jesus Christ
um but this is this is is where we're at
in this country right now so sad things
but you know I'll tell you a Shining
Light here is that people in the in in
that community and other communities
around the country are not going to put
up with gun violence anymore it feels
like we aren't turning a corner that
Americans just are not going to go out
and be scared because some crazy batshit
idiot that has access to guns because
Republicans want anyone and everyone to
have access to guns has got a gun and
can kill them their children their
friends their family members their
Community it's I I just don't feel like
we're we're in a position where where
we're gonna put up with this much longer
I I just don't feel that way how about
you yeah the kids had it and we saw that
in Tennessee
um and we saw Governor Bill Lee kind of
they pushed his hand to sign Common
Sense gun legislation because they're
not putting up with it anymore and the
story you referenced is is Ralph yarl
and um a young black boy who
isn't just an everyday kid he was a
Missouri scholar there are not very many
kids chosen to be a Missouri scholar he
was all state band
um this is he's like one of the highest
ranked uh base saxophone or bass
clarinet um I forget which
um but he's he's really good at playing
an instrument like he's really he's
really it sounds like he's really good
at being a good human being and he went
to pick up a sibling and uh accidentally
went down the wrong Street and um a
white guy came to his door and shot
Ralph through the glass door and walked
out and shot him again
um as he lie on the ground and you're
right yesterday the community came
together I think there were 200 300
people marching through that
neighborhood demanding Justice for Ralph
um and that's the the point of this
entire thing is this is Missouri gun
culture this is GOP gun culture I'm a
gun owner myself I have been desperately
trying to call for common sense gun
regulation and laws since I joined Mom's
demand back in 2017. there's 75 80
percent of Americans want Common Sense
gun regulations what they're doing in
these gerrymandered red States like mine
is they are not listening to the
constituents they are listening to the
extremists they're listening to donors
and then they are refusing to pass laws
or they are creating even worse laws I
know that you know in Missouri we had
the Second Amendment preservation act
which nullified federal gun laws and
it's just now being taken up in court
almost two years later but I would talk
about this I would talk about the fact
that Missouri nullified federal gun laws
and people would say they can't do that
and you're like come to Missouri friend
come to Missouri
well um we have Gabe Sanchez here and
he's a little late today you know it
happens it's Monday morning so uh but
Gabe Sanchez is joining us but um you
know
we we I think Saturday there was nine
mass shootings
um in this country I think that was
Saturday uh in Alabama we watched as a
as a sweet 16 party there was four
killed 28 injured
um and it it and the list goes on and on
in Louisville in a park just just a just
a ways away from where the bank was last
week
um where someone
got access to a gun he went and bought
the gun days before and went and carried
out the ACT uh early in the morning in
the bank
um get killed I think it's six or seven
now I mean it's hard to keep track of
every single one of these mass shootings
so it's not just a person-to-person gun
violence like in Ralph's case where
Ralph ended up on the wrong Street on
the wrong porch on the wrong side of a
gun but it's also these mass shootings
that are terrorizing uh Americans and uh
it just feels like to me with what is
happening in Tennessee
um that there is a consensus in this
country that we can't put up with this
anymore but it doesn't deter Republicans
yes it doesn't deter them at all we see
Jim Jordan this morning Jim Jordan of
Ohio that which I can't even believe I
have to say these words out of my mouth
Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan who
is the chairman of the Judiciary
Committee goes on a field trip to New or
City
um in his attempt to act like they're
talking about violence and crime in New
York City Jess New York City is one per
capita is one of the safest places to be
in the country I wonder what it could be
really honestly I wonder if there's like
I don't know restrictions on Firearms
inside the city like sale or caring or
concealing it's almost like there's this
I don't know thing like Common Sense gun
safety that keeps people in New York
um safer I don't know it could be that
it could be that but this morning in
this hearing Democrats are bringing up
gun violence and guns and the
Republicans absolutely are not deterred
they deflect away from Guns because you
go after these Republicans I mentioned
it before the Brew you're on them all
the time and and the the best the
your best interactions are when you're
interacting with some of the scumbags in
the Missouri legislator right
um because I I I know some of these I
don't know them personally but I've I've
been around some of these people and
trust me they're not who they think they
are on social media or when they're on
the house floor the senate floor but
um Jess what can we do because you're
you're in the fight every day so what
can what can average people do about
Republicans
seemingly
just they don't care about the blood
Money of the NRA they don't care about
the blood Money of the of the gun lobby
because they only want that they don't
want to protect their constituents what
do we do about it well it comes down to
them uh basically and I was just talking
about this earlier today
um in Missouri in red States like
Missouri Ohio
um you know all these states in the
Midwest and the South we are made to be
responsible for managing the emotions of
armed white guys
if you know Ralph knocked on the the
wrong door and he was shot and that man
is not in jail because Missouri says you
don't even have to retreat if you feel
like you're in danger you can shoot
through a glass door and shoot a child
in the head and you can stay out of jail
because that's what's going on in
Missouri you can open carry a gun at 19
with no permit and no license we just
made it you know the Democrats tried to
bring up a bill to ban children from
carrying guns on public land and that
was a step too far for the Republicans
they were absolutely not you know
um so we're at a place where we can't
negotiate with them there's no
negotiation anymore we have to make sure
that they are out of office and people
will say this all the time
um you know you guys vote against your
self-interest and you know this because
I've said it before 40 of House Seats
were not were not contested last year
how in God's name can people vote in
their self-interest if there is no
Democrat on their ticket so we as the
party have to get together and make sure
that there is absolutely not one state
race that is uncontested across the
state because until they are fearful
that they are going to lose their job
they are going to do nothing and if all
else fails and you can't find a Democrat
find a moderate Republican and say okay
we're going to primary you then we're
going to make sure that you lose in the
primary we have gotten to a place um in
Missouri you know with the Democratic
party we're in panic mode we don't have
any elected Democrats Statewide we're
making knee-jerk decisions we're trying
to calm down and trying to you know do a
long-term plan but when you're literally
under the gun I mean it's it's getting
you know it's it's hard to live here and
I'll tell you that's the point they
don't want us living here the they want
us moving out to cities or they want us
to move out of the states I'm sure they
would be absolutely tickled to death if
I went to California just like they told
me to right if I moved to New York just
like they told me to I've walked New
York streets I feel perfectly safe there
sometimes in Springfield Missouri I
don't feel so safe right oh by the way
that's a republican-led city so they
don't understand how math works that
when you have a bigger population that
you're going to have more crime right I
mean that sounds like good reason but
they're also using guns as an
intimidation Factor if you don't do what
we say if you try to restrict uh us at
all we'll kill you I mean literally
that's that's what they're saying
without saying it so much and that's why
I interact so much with elected
Republicans that's why they hate my guts
that's why they have four or five
different Twitter accounts you know
coming at me you know they're supposed
to be that's why they call me a state
senator Nick Shore called me on my phone
and left voicemail trying to do a gotcha
interview while I was speaking in
Lawrence Kansas like these people make
memes they make accounts they they call
people citizens but they're not doing
their freaking job
well and and I love that about you that
you're you're on them and you're not
scared of them and you let them know
that you're not scared of them and
that's what scares them about you right
that's what scares them about you're not
an elected official yeah do you do you
have any power inside the government at
all
are you do you have big money behind you
lobbying the government Jess Piper do
you because it feels like it feels like
to me that the only thing you try to do
is to make sure that missourians like
you as a parent as a mother as a teacher
as a community member have a voice and
that's that's what anyone wants right
yeah I I live on a farm in a house that
I paid twenty nine thousand dollars for
I don't I'm not cashing checks from
anybody I'm not I'm not supported by the
nea I work with them occasionally they
don't send me a dime
um you can look at you can look at
everything I raise more money than
anybody across the state for a state
race last term I didn't take a salary
I'm I'm not in this for money I'm in it
because my kids and grandkids live here
and Missouri has become untenable and we
we can't stay forever if nothing's going
to change it has to change and that's
what they're scared about I've got
nothing to lose what are they going to
do not fund my road not fund my schools
take away my health care they did it
friends they got nothing on me nothing
well you know your um your buddy online
Nick because he's um it seems like
you're his arch enemy right your enemy
number one for him he's a pretty fragile
little guy he really is he's a fragile
little guy and and you know what you
know what it's funny I've seen him in
person out and about I've seen him in
person out and about and let me tell you
something about males and alpha males
Nick is definitely no alpha male let me
tell you something like up close and
personal and Nick you probably know what
I'm talking about because you'll
probably watch this because you can't
help you can't help but be everywhere
Jess is because she's your arch enemy so
buddy I hate to tell you man but the
mustache just doesn't do it that well it
just doesn't project so my advice to
Nick my advice to Nick is to do your job
that's what you should be doing instead
of focusing on Twitter and and doing the
gotcha thing on the quote tweet suggests
maybe what you should do is I don't know
think about what constituents you
represent and go do that go do that in
Jefferson City and I'm calling on all
Republicans everywhere not just in
Missouri but everywhere in Tennessee in
New York in the United States House of
Representatives do your job Hey
Kevin McCarthy how about if you want
Biden to come to the table how about you
go to the table and this is what they do
Jess and it's not just at the federal
level it's not just at State levels it's
at County levels it's at school boards
every single place that they can get
their hands on power they're trying to
make sure that they they Institute to
own the libs policy right how in the
world do they survive this if it's own
the libs 24 hours a day seven days a
week because that's what Nick kind of
does with you on social media right
instead of doing this job in Jeff City
and representing his constituents he's
doing the the own the libs own the Jess
online it's kind of hilarious actually
Nick and people like Nick are scared of
folks like me because I am what they act
like they are I'm born and bred rule I
live in the middle of nowhere I send my
kids to Public Schools I'm a gun owner I
have five kids and three grandkids and
I'm an everyday American and they're
trying to make me something they cannot
and they're trying to be me but they
live in gated communities you know along
in St Louis they're not me but the whole
point of this is that it's it's the red
state legislators and I hope the people
I say this all the time don't focus on
DC look at your state house you want to
look at abortion bands and book bands
and you know bands on trans kids
Healthcare in in Missouri it's trans
adults now who cannot receive Health
Care look at your state house they can't
run on their records the Missouri GOP
has been in power for two decades 20
years every single thing that is wrong
and Unholy with this state has
originated from a policy from a GOP
um you know state legislator or Senator
I can't have it's hard for them to scoop
snow off of my road I can pick up pieces
of asphalt and bring it in my house if I
want to because that's what my road
looks like right our schools have gone
down to four days a week kids miss 36
days of school every single year out in
rural Missouri because they refuse to
fund it and then when we had bad test
scores they run to find a camera to talk
about how crappy you know Missouri
teachers and schools are you defended it
you took the money away from it you got
exactly what you wanted which is
privatizing schools all of this comes to
this you talk to your neighbors you post
online everybody you talk to you say we
have elected Republicans out here for 20
years and look at what they have done
Mike Parson just over the weekend was
talking about bringing International
businesses to St Louis and he said he
was struggling because the nasty press
crop coverage and I'm like Mike it ain't
the Press coverage it's what you're
doing people are not going to bring
employees and businesses to states that
ban abortion and don't don't fund
libraries you don't fund your schools
you can't find someone to take care of
your kid and we can't drive on the road
Mike no one's coming
yeah well no there's go ahead I was
going to say there's a there's a few
things you've said in there one is it
really goes to show you I mean how
fragile or how weak or how sensitive
another guy like Nick can be like the
fact that he's a sitting representative
for the state of Missouri and he's taken
out his day right of the time that he
should spend representing constituents
much like Jim Jordan is going on a field
trip to New York to try to own Alvin
Bragg even though Alvin Bragg's like
look we literally have the stats the
crime has gone down in all of these
categories literally across the board oh
he's got a whole thread of it this
morning it's it's great to see right
like because it what happens here is you
see Republicans say hey I'm going to own
the lips right I'm going to own them so
hard and they're gonna have to prove it
and they're like okay bet I approved it
here it is here are the numbers here are
the figures here the stats here's the
actual data despite the fact that we
know you guys don't like math you want
to ban math you don't want to accept the
math the basic arithmetic that stands in
front of you
so it's funny to see someone who
you know sees you as a threat because
you are a threat right you actually
represent American values you know uh I
saw someone in the chat say uh
uh
what was it it was
I'll try to find in a second but it was
it was a it was a phrase um dirt road
Democrats is that what it was no it was
uh because that's that that's what
Jess's uh podcast is called dirt road
Democrats no it was because there are
dirt road Democrats out there born bred
corn fed definitely there you go yeah
but but you you look at you look at
someone like Nick and you see it's a
pretty common theme across Republicans
they always hate anyone who actually
says hey let's actually look at the
problem right let's not try to sugarcoat
it or say oh we can't do it right now
because I've got some lobbyists paying
me money or whatever it might be but
then the other thing too is like
you you look at how the Republican party
has abandoned Americans right and you
look at uh you know the example you just
gave of of trying to bring international
business in why would anyone ever want
to leave their country for a shittier
situation right if the roads aren't uh
kept up and they're not maintained if
the school and education system is worse
than it is in their country if the
health care is worse than it is in their
country if the uh human rights are worse
than it is in their country why would
any business say hey come on over to
Missouri we've got a great international
business scene and we want you to move
here the hell with International it's
going to become American soon right
exactly American companies aren't even
going to want to go to American states
because they're going to choose they're
going to choose a state that has better
education better educated people that
care about I don't know even simple
nutrition for children I mean to imagine
to imagine in this country that
manufactures here's the choice they're
going to make manufacturer is going to
make a choice Jess Piper they're going
to say okay we can go to Missouri where
they won't even feed children so that
they grow up to be educated fully
nutrition adults or we'll go to I don't
know some state that binds nutrition uh
I don't know like it's essential to
Children's Learning and then maybe
because they fund education a little
better they'll be a little better
educated so maybe maybe they'll make
better employees because I don't know
they make smarter logical rational
decisions when they're working for us I
mean these things are so simple to
understand but but Jess I want to touch
on something and it's kind of anecdotal
some folks I know um who are who are Die
Hard trumpers they're Cuban honors I
mean it's kind of sad they're part of
the family but
um they were they were in a conversation
this weekend and they had no idea not a
single clue that Republicans in
the state of Missouri had defunded every
single nickel of public libraries and
when they heard that they were outraged
they were outraged and folks I think the
point is here and just speak on this
because I know you try to yell at the
top of your lungs right I always say I
have one microphone but everyone out
there has thousands of microphones use
them and and so I want you to tell folks
how to use their microphone because it
really isn't that people Rule people
like you're talking about don't care
about these things or don't want public
libraries they don't want their Public
Schools I mean hell in most rural
communities that's the biggest employer
in the entire Community is the school
like the school is the biggest employer
in some of those communities so tell us
how do you use your microphone to let
folks know that yes they're defunding
libraries yes they're defunding schools
and let me tell you something this
defunding library is not going to affect
libraries in very big heavy populated
areas because those libraries are funded
by property tax the rural communities
are the ones that are going to lose
their libraries access to the internet
access to free rentable movies access to
newspapers access to the outside world
sometimes in those cases in those rural
communities so tell us what we do with
our microphones because I think that's
the most important thing is to tell
people what they're doing because they
just don't know
yeah the economics of Republican
policies have got us to where we are
right now so when people when my
neighbors look at the fact that we only
have a gas station in town now we don't
have any place to say buy milk or that
sort of thing
um that is Republican policy
um my the fact that we can't scoop our
roads and we only have chip and seal on
all the roads in town and they've
basically degraded down to gravel that's
Republican policy the fact that we don't
have a Performing Arts Center that we
have to co-op for sports so that we have
a field to play on the fact that our you
know science books are from 2002 those
Republican policies so you have to talk
to folks about what they're worried
about the hospital in our area was
forced to consolidate because we didn't
expand Medicaid which is a republican
policy when we Consolidated we lost one
of the biggest child care centers in our
district it had 180 kids there we live
in a child care desert if if you cannot
find affordable child care affordable
living affordable way you know livable
wages those are all Republican policies
so you have to be very specific about
what you're talking about we have one
library in my County
they will probably have to either
shorten the days or reduce the days or
reduce
um you know the programs that they put
on because like you said St Louis
libraries are probably going to make it
through this libraries in my area will
not and so all of these things when I
knock a door when I talk to somebody the
first thing they do is they don't like
Democrats because they don't like Joe
bidener they don't like Nancy Pelosi and
I always have to say you know Nancy
Pelosi doesn't know where Maryville
Missouri is Joe Biden the only thing he
does is write a check for the highway
like that's that's the only thing they
have to do with our area but your
Republican representative just voted to
defend your schools they voted to defend
your libraries and our libraries May
close so it's called Deep canvassing
it's talking to people and having long
conversations which takes a lot of folks
it can't just be me right I'll tell you
one other thing too I knocked a lot of
doors and I talked to a lot of folks
that did not vote for me but they saw me
they heard me I don't look like a you
know like I eat babies I don't have
horns so maybe the next time they're
like
she seemed like an okay person I thought
you hid your horns for the show I
thought you hid your horn for the show
well you know you know the other thing
that I think is remarkable
um because 10 years ago 15 years ago we
didn't have this a lot of people don't
know this Republicans in the state of
Missouri like the people the Republicans
who represent Constitution the state of
Missouri and people in Missouri
definitely know this they've been
scumbags for a long time and they say
vile nasty things about their
constituents about other missourians on
the house floor and they've been saying
it for decades they're they're I I hate
to say it like this but they're pieces
of and they have been for a long
time it's just no one's paid attention
no one has paid attention and last week
I believe you and others took a hearing
that Mike moon was in and he was trying
to defend his vote on 12 year old girls
being married because let's face it
they're not talking about 12 year old
boys being married that's not what
they're talking about I I I I
would guarantee I would guarantee the
first 12 year old boy that gets married
to a 30 year old 30 year old woman the
Republicans would go to the house floor
and they'd pass a bill where a a 12 year
old boy can never lose his manhood and
his his his ability to be an alpha male
in the future to be married off to some
30 year old woman I guarantee that have
legislation the very next day it's about
marrying young girls and Mike Moon gave
away gave away the secret uh in
this hearing not only did he give away
the secret it was posted online and
because we have the opportunity to
spread this stuff around and make people
know what's happening in these State
houses the same way has happened in
Tennessee and and all likelihood speaker
sexton in Tennessee has turned uh Justin
Jones and Justin Pearson in the Civil
Rights icons at this point but here's
the thing bringing this stuff to light
in these hearings on social media and
spreading around to show that who they
truly are Mike moon goes on to to make a
video last week that absolutely not only
not only did he decide to use a shovel
to bury his or to dig his political
grave he's like bring in the backhoe
baby let's bring in the backhoe and I'll
use Jesus and God on why I'm justifying
that 12 year old girls should get
married and why it's a good thing and
I'm not sure if the media has really
um gave any kind of real test on his
story that he keeps telling which I I
actually the story sounds like
to me and until he would prove it I'm
gonna say it's so I don't give
a about that but Mike Moon last
week it was just a and I think it's like
a 30 second clip that was posted online
do you think that's one of the most
effective ways and the reason why
they're so terrified of people like you
on social media because they say one
wrong thing in a meme that's recorded
you post it and Bam they're having to
give a hostage video like Mike moon was
giving to desperately cling on to their
state senatorship because they want to
be a lobbyist one day in Missouri they
don't want to be you know Cast Away as a
pedophile that they truly are so tell
tell us why that's so effective because
you do it so well on social media but
what is it about what is it about
exposing these idiots
um and really they're idiocy on policy
what is it about that that's so
effective
this is why they want to ban Tick Tock
this is the real reason is because we
have access now
um people who people work all day long
all three of us are very privileged to
sit here and talk about politics right
we are not at Kawasaki on the line right
now
um so we we are paying attention but
other folks don't have time to do that
they're working two or three jobs
they've got kids they've got to make
supper they're busy these clips and I
tell it to all my friends in the
Missouri you know Democrats all those
legislators get a clip send it to me I
will use it because I mean for good and
for bad Mike Moon got himself caught up
because Mike moon has never been held
accountable for anything he has ever
said or done and he was caught up
because he was held accountable in that
moment because even conservatives will
say that's not okay you can't talk about
it being okay to marry off children
um and so he get himself into trouble
that you're exactly right he looked like
he was reading a hostage statement and
then he went into to God the last minute
or so so we have an issue with
unaccountable legislators we have a
definite issue with the separation of
church and state we have an issue with
men in Missouri that are in the
legislator and some women in fact that
view women as nothing more than chattel
right
um they don't care about our rights they
don't care about our education They
Don't Care About Us while we're pregnant
They Don't Care About Us after we give
birth they don't care about the children
if they were pro-life like they all say
if they they were pro-life they would be
making sure that girls didn't
accidentally get pregnant in the first
place and that they were able to make a
choice about you know their lives
afterwards they would make sure that
children have child care and health care
and a safe place to live and that their
parents make livable wages so that they
aren't under this umbrella of poverty
that absolutely can implode in things
like domestic violence drug abuse that
sort of thing these people are not
pro-life and I'm gonna tell you they're
not serious people they're not serious
at all there there are a couple I've met
a couple of Republicans down in Jeff
City who are really trying to work their
way out of this because they are decent
people but it's hard when you have these
other people that are you know
representing you as a whole
um and to them I suggest this maybe be
an independent or vote like your
conscience tells you to and reject the
party line
but that's the thing they are they are
never held accountable and everyone in
Missouri and in Ohio and in states with
super majorities should say just like in
Texas you have been in charge for 20
years in my district 30 years we haven't
elected a democrat in 30 years there is
absolutely not one Democrat you can pin
any of this on
well I couldn't agree more and I am so
glad that you are out there holding them
accountable and we will try to keep
doing our best to hold them accountable
everyone go follow Jess anywhere you can
here's the thing the link tree her link
tree is down in the description below
and just tell us where they can find you
though but the link trees down below but
where can they find you so on Twitter
Facebook and Instagram I'm Piper for
Missouri the number four on Tick Tock
they can find me at justpiper Mo
um and then yeah I would love for you
guys to follow me and help me with the
messaging get it out I've got a pretty
big account which is another reason why
they're so scared of me but let's on
Twitter I'd love to be at 100K they
would uh their pants let's do it
let's let's make it to where Republicans
in Missouri have the arch enemy of just
for Piper for Missouri on Twitter and
they their their fascist parents I
love it Jess I love your brand of
liberalism I truly do
um I think it fits in right with our
show I think it fits in with me and um I
want to have you back more and more and
get your messaging out there uh it's so
good to talk to you and I hope we can
continue these conversations uh now and
into the future so Jess thank you for
joining us we appreciate having you and
I know the audience loves you so
everyone again go go to Jess's link tree
and follow follow Jess us anywhere you
can everyone stick around thank you Jess
for joining us stick around we'll be
right back right after this
[Music]
mark
is the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product part in blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
this microphone
kills fascism
that's what it does oh and it does a
good job of picking up my singing
here's the thing is that I last night
when we started the um patreon karaoke
party I couldn't get it to work right I
worked for like an hour before to figure
out Zoom it is so zoom zoom is
so clunky and zoom you know what
if you want here here's here's thing
Zoom if you want to to
um prove me wrong give me a free
lifetime subscription support the show
here and I wouldn't mind just use zoom I
don't know but uh it is clunky as hell
there is so many options it's so stupid
but I finally figured out I finally
figured out how to share the sound
um and we did a little karaoke I showed
some comedy
um that I like from Wayne Fleming of uh
of Canada
his rendition of rinderzilla so we
showed that last night on the patreon
party I took some great questions from
the audience
um on Zoom so they came on and they
asked some questions and they had a lot
of great things to say not just about me
but they said them about you too I think
they were lying but they said them about
you do that right now I don't know man I
can't trust them can't trust them no I
and I even if you go back and watch the
tape because the again the tape with the
90s things like that roll the tape but
here's the thing it's on it's on the
YouTube channel so if you want to go
re-watch
um the patreon party last night Gabe
Sanchez does eventually chime in with
his beautiful voice
um but I said great things about you too
I said that we couldn't do this show
without you that it's it's um because we
couldn't do the show without you too
yeah well I mean obviously what the hell
would you I mean what would the verse 30
minutes just be quiet it would just be
it would just be a Zen like right like
you know when you go get a massage and
play like elevator music
when you're in a massage it's like it's
like a babbling brook or like oh okay uh
you know week or like some sort of like
something soothing yeah you know some
something really nice oh okay so that's
what I would imagine I'm trash to me
yeah it would be actually you know
what's funny so for those who didn't
make it yesterday Tony and I did uh an
earlier show for my weekend Roundup and
uh this is true and I was on time for
that one yeah yeah I mean I was right on
that was early I was actually early you
know
so
so someone someone left a comment like
an hour after the show and they're like
oh like someone's like oh I missed the
show or like I missed it like damn you
know and they're watching and then
someone else commented they're like
I've never seen Tony this tame before or
like yeah they said oh well because I
was a guest on yours so I know but I was
like yeah I feel like you know I have
the ability to like bring him down a bit
right uh but what did somebody say I was
I was taking your lead on it right
because yeah it's totally fine I mean
it's just it's it's an open it's an open
platform where we're just like hey man
here are a few stories on some crazy
and also it's like doesn't always
have to be about politics anything
that's happening
anywhere else where you're like whoa
what was that you know
um and you know that's the whole point
of like you know Roundup of some things
that maybe we didn't catch or just some
like tacking on some additional stuff
but yeah somebody was like um
I thought they said big staff Fame on
them um twitch says was Tony hi no I
wasn't high no no I was drinking for my
thing but I I had not started drinking
until yeah so somebody somebody wrote
somebody wrote hold on let me see if I
can find it couldn't watch live enjoying
it now
questions on replay hot damn you got a
weekend show too that's great okay
man somebody said something about oh oh
here we go the storm Virgil said oh man
I missed this one never heard Tony talk
so calmly before LOL
I guess it just does it to me when we're
yeah
I was you know because you know the
other thing is I had no controls because
I was on Gabe's software which I granted
permission on mine but he didn't oh yeah
I should I didn't even realize no like I
I I couldn't control anything so I
actually scooted back my keyboard and
all my stuff look at that I didn't have
to worry about what what I was what was
gonna play or wasn't gonna play or how
the show is gonna go if there was break
I didn't give a really I was there
just there to hang out I was there to
hang man give my opinion every once in a
while so and it turned out great it was
a great show so if you want listen if
you want to see now the special q a in
in the uh week week Roundup with Gabe
goto what was that show.com that's what
was that show.com it takes you directly
to his patreon or you can go to
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez why you're
on patreon come over to mine to
patreon.com
Tony Michaels you check mine out too and
again if you want to watch the um the
patreon party from last night and
Karaoke If you you can fast forward it
all the way to the end and I'm singing
baby I'm building Tunes
um someone said someone said because I
sang Garth Brooks Two of a Kind Two of a
Kind work you don't know that song uh
you didn't know anything I don't listen
to Country I mean I know these people I
joked I was like I don't know Garth
Brooks who's that man I mean I know
these artists obviously some songs I do
know but for the most part like I'm not
that demographic
someone said that I sang Two of a Kind
better than Garth Brooks and I'm like
whoa damn I don't think I don't think
that's true I mean it may be it may be
true it may be true but you know so if
you want to check that out go to
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez or
patreon.com the Tony Michaels and you
can Jay got our patreon page what do you
got for us speaking of what was that
what do you got for us today what's the
um what what's this new this new episode
on
this new episode that can give me the
link by the way yeah yeah yeah yeah and
now I'll play I mean I gotta have a link
and I'll play it yeah I haven't even I
haven't even made this public yet so oh
really yeah yeah I'll make it public
after the show
um is it a private link or unlisted
okay so like the people the people on
patreon have already had a couple days
they got the they got the the Early
Access the fresh scoop the early you
know the the good take on it
um and then uh uh I'll I'll make it I'll
make it public after the show but okay
this is uh you know
this is for those who don't know this is
a what was that episode and the the
topic is just to set it up in Florida
there's a there's a guy named Webster
Barnaby and he went on this crazy
vitriolic
transphobic rant and he called trans
people demons imps and mutants and so I
take an opportunity to really go
into this guy and break down what he
said okay well let's take a look at the
newest what was that here we go
I'm looking at society today
and it's like I'm watching an X-Men
movie
uh with
people that when you watch the X-Men
movies
for Marvel Comics
it's like we have mutants living among
us on planet Earth
and you know
some people don't like that but that's a
fact there is so much darkness in our
world today
so much evil in our world today
and so many people who are afraid to
address the evil the dysphoria the
dysfunction
I'm not afraid to address the dysphoria
or the dysfunction
the Lord rebuke you Satan and all of
your demons and all of your imps who
come and parade before us
that's right I called you demons and
imps who come and parade before us
and pretend that you are part of this
world whoa what was that that's right I
called you demons and imps who come and
parade before us
and pretend that you are part of this
world representative Webster Barnaby
Unleashed an unhinged transphobic rant
during a Committee hearing calling
transgender Floridians mutants demons
and imps so I guess Republicans are just
saying the quiet part out loud now
[Music]
Republican leaders in Florida are trying
to pass House Bill 1521 which would
criminalize trans people who use a
bathroom that doesn't align with the sex
that they were assigned at Birth this is
just one of several bathroom bills that
are gaining Traction in conservative
leaning States but let's call what it
really is a transgender bathroom ban
bill that's aimed at punishing the trans
Community it's not only moronic and
transphobic but there are no standards
on how to implement and enforce this
bill are you going to deputize the
public so you're now going to tell the
public after you rile them up with all
your tweets and all your memes that
trans people are trying to hurt their
children now tell them that they can now
walk into the bathroom and check
someone's genitals
a better way to say this is who's going
to check all of our panties are y'all
going to check my panties who is going
to DARE go check my daughter's pull-up
because that is one of those sappho
moments that's really big and very
important I think anyone with a child
with a child would say the same thing
Republicans never think they're lost
through they drum up their base with
fear-mongering and then refuse to take
responsibility when their plan
inevitably shits the bed I don't know
what genitals you have under your
clothes and I don't know what's on your
birth certificate and frankly that
information is none of my business
this bill is ridiculous because it's
practically unenforceable on the
day-to-day level but when it is enforced
it's designed solely to segregate and
discriminate against trans people and
it's the opposite of safety for them
Republicans are the same group of
snowflakes who whine about big
government overreach but then use big
government overreach to tell people what
bathroom they can go into it's simple
really Republicans just need to keep
their hands out of other people's pants
and mine their own business you know for
a group that claims Democrats or
groomers and pedophiles Republicans sure
are obsessed with inspecting other
people's genitalia but when you realize
the Republican party is full of groomers
pedophiles and sexual predators their
projection makes total sense Republicans
rely heavily on using fake outrage and
debunk transphobic bathroom myths to
push their hateful agenda in fact
according to a 2018 study there is no
evidence that letting transgender people
use public facilities that align with
their gender identity increases safety
risks for others you would only be
regulating law-abiding trans people that
just want to pee there's no need need
for that you're not going to stop the
bad guys that want to assault women in
restrooms because those are CIS men we
we do not have some problem with trans
folks assaulting people in bathrooms
that's not happening there is a problem
with CIS men maybe address that problem
and another study found that transgender
teens in schools with bathroom
restrictions are actually at a higher
risk of sexual assault in my high school
I knew a few trans kids and they would
literally have their friends act as
bodyguards for them to go to the
bathroom they would have to coordinate
and hold it for hours until they were
able to do so and again I find it rich
that the Republican Party who loves to
complain about the government invading
their privacy is perfectly content with
invading the privacy of the trans
Community the Republican party's weird
obsession with the Trans Community is
actually going to make people less safe
and this bill is just one of a series of
proposals that Republicans are moving
through the legislator to attack trans
people why are you so obsessed with me
the bathroom ban is as useless as the
Republican Party itself I urge you to
Google the repercussions of this the
same band in North Carolina bathroom
bands are bad for business trans people
have always been here they will always
be here and they will always use the
bathroom this is just another solution
in search of a problem much like all the
other oppressive bills making their way
through this session this will have
unintended consequences even outside of
the queer community and I urge you to
vote down on this bill in 2016 North
Carolina enacted a similar bill which
faced widespread blowback from
businesses the NBA and the NCAA and
eventually the law was repealed look
there are endless issues actual issues
that Republicans could be focused on but
instead they're trying to be the
Pediatric penis police but that's not
stopping Republicans like representative
Webster Barnaby from going off on a
vitriolic rant against trans people I'm
looking at society today
and it's like I'm watching an X-Men
movie
with
people that when you watch the X-Men
movies
for Marvel Comics
it's like we have mutants living among
us on planet Earth
and you know
some people don't like that but that's a
fact we have people that live among us
today on planet Earth
that
are happy to display themselves
as if they were mutants from another
planet
this is the planet Earth
where God crew
female
I'm a proud Christian Conservative
Republican
I'm not on the fence Barnaby's whole
rant is a perfect example of a
republican claiming to be a Christian
and then immediately attacking a fellow
human just for existing so much for
following the word of God and loving thy
neighbor I guess there is so much
darkness in our world today
so much evil in our world today
and so many people who are afraid to
address the evil the dysphoria the
dysfunction
I'm not afraid to address the dysphoria
or the dysfunction
the Lord rebuke you Satan and all of
your demons and all of your imps who
come and parade before us
that's right I called you demons and
imps who come and parade before us
and pretend that you are part of this
world
so I'm I'm saying my righteous
indignation is stirred I am sick and
tired of this
we I'm not going to put up with it
you can test me and try to take me on
but I promise you I'll win every time he
directly compared trans people to
mutants and X-Men and then called the
trans people in the room demons and imps
I mean it's almost like Barnaby was
trying to reenact the scene from the
first X-Men movie I think the American
people deserve the right to decide
whether they want their children to be
in school with mutants to be taught by
mutants ladies and gentlemen
the truth is
that mutants are very real and they are
among us we must know who they are
and above all we must know
what they can do the X-Men are about
fighting against racism and bigotry
striving to make Society better for
every group of people that the majority
tries to destroy and oppress which means
that Barnaby watched X-Men and then just
actively decided that he wanted to be
the villain Dr Bolivar Trask and this is
exactly what triggered bigot Barnaby to
go off on his bizarre transphobic tirade
when I need to use the bathroom that's
cool who do you propose regulates which
door I go through
if you want adults checking the
genitalia of students I would worry who
hears the real predator and who is the
real victim I trust trans people as
Republicans you need to look out for how
do we expect to enforce this transphobic
legislation
because I don't want people looking at
my genitals because that would make
Joy or not I can pee as defined within
the bill people of in the restroom
correspond to the opposite sex which for
Trans people would be the restroom
correspondent their gender would
be endangering other people in the
restroom to the point where others are
able to actually have precedence over
them in the restroom this creates a huge
civil rights issue this bill is
dangerous and has the potential to try
and traumatize anyone that identifies as
female
uh because let's be honest that this
bill is made in trans misogyny being
against trans feminine folks that aren't
seen as CIS passing in society uh it was
made in this unreal fear that men are in
the women's bathroom and then these
so-called men are cisgender men and not
trans women good afternoon
my name is Caleb pops and Garcia I'm a
trans man this bathroom band is just
another piece of the nationally
quartered coordinated effort by
far-right Christian billionaires like
Betsy DeVos to erase trans people from
society because we do not fit into a
narrow religiously motivated worldview
transgender people are Floridians or
students workers and Business Leaders
where parents siblings Aunts Uncles and
children we work hard we contribute to
our communities we pay more in taxes
than the far-right billionaires who fund
the AstroTurf campaigns do these are the
exact kind of bills designed to put my
life in danger and in fact I've legally
changed my gender marker from female to
male it says mail on my driver's license
if I am legally male how would they
prove that I am transgender are the
police going to make me pull my pants
down
I wish you were obsessed with housing
Healthcare education and corporate taxes
or you are with the genitals of men like
me thank you this bill is Extreme it's
dangerous it's creepy vote no this is
what Barnaby got so upset about
testimony from lgbtq Advocates and
transgender people who oppose the
measure it was an excuse for Barnaby to
punch down on a group that's already
taken a beating from other Progressive
States across the country it should be
noted that Barnaby later apologized for
making the hateful comments but let's be
honest he meant what he said look I know
Barnaby supported the don't say gay Bill
and that he also hates Disney but I
think you could actually learn an
important lesson from Bambi if you can't
say something nice
yes
don't say nothing at all oh and here's a
thought maybe instead of attacking a
minority group that has a long history
of being beaten down both verbally and
physically you sit listen and most
importantly keep your mouth shut
remember when people tell you who they
are believe them well until next episode
I'm Gabe Sanchez and this has been what
was that if you enjoyed today's episode
and want to support the work that goes
into creating the what was that show you
can join my patreon at
whatwizthatchow.com you'll get access to
early episodes exclusive bits behind the
scenes content access to the show's
private Discord as well as live q and
A's to connect directly with me to offer
up comments questions and suggested
topics to be featured on the show thanks
again for watching and I hope to see you
over on patreon
so that was what was that I think you
gave Sanchez for another great episode
yeah yeah yeah what was that I saw
someone say it wasn't Bambi it was
Thumper no I'm I was I'm talking about
the movie Bambi not now I know who
Thumper is very well placed by the way
yeah yeah yeah it was nothing nice don't
say nothing when I was uh I was like
finishing it up and I was like oh I was
gonna put a golden rule in there right
like you know uh treat others how you
want to be treated right and then I was
like oh wait hold on I'm pretty sure in
one of these films somebody said this
lesson and then I was like ah it's just
so awesome it's perfect it's
perfect so and great job on this newest
episode of what was that again everyone
if you want to get early access to what
was that show what was that show.com
that's what was that show.com it'll take
you directly to Gabe Sanchez's patreon
page and you'll get the Early Access to
what was that and
his early access to his great political
um
I've got a few a few commercials that
I'm oh are we gonna get new commercials
you know I actually went back and I
looked do you remember the uh
um the binder commercial what's it
called the boycott binder boycott binder
and I was like man I wish but light was
in there but I was like that we need to
we need to bust that one out again oh
yeah the boycott binder is great yeah so
I think what I'll do this week is I'll
I'll put boycott binder back in the
rotation okay now since they're you know
it never gets old I mean I made one
there's a video I need to actually put
up it was made in 2021 and it was during
the time that
um
that uh they were freaking out about Bud
Light right so they're like Bud Light
back's vaccine we came we're Banning
them and it's a Sketcher and me I'm in
front of that last
yeah not very long they were like man
many men
and so basically drinking Bud Light like
I can't afford that expensive non-woke
beer I need to go back to the woke beer
right and I think well the if you if you
watch the video which I'll put online
the idea is that uh everything's been
banned right right singers uh companies
beer all these people have been banned
because they either supported BLM or
they supported the vaccine or they were
woke so they're just a huge wall of band
companies and I'm like let's do this
let's do Sonic let's do Coke let's do
you know Delta whatever all of them all
of them every single one of them
and these are the people like oh we
don't like cancer culture you're just
trying to cancel us and that's all they
do is yeah yeah they're like oh no and
it's like I get that you want to feel
like your life is difficult or that you
feel oppressed but
if you
put it out there to say
um
like if someone if a republican were to
go out there and be like Oh I Feel So
oppressed because of this like you're
creating the problem that you are now
the product of like you're saying that
you know you you guys canceled or you
know banned this company and then you're
saying that you can't have access to it
because you guys canceled it like it
doesn't work that way this isn't like
someone else doing this act on you you
guys actively chose to do this and then
you complain about the fact that you
can't have it right so that's all the
Republicans do they could
and moan about and it's like look
man pull yourself away your bootstrap
stop bitching and stop being a ass
okay stop being a if there
was ever a mantra of 2023 and Beyond
it's don't be a ass it is
true and now these ass
went to New York City this morning all
right yeah I haven't seen any videos
Jim Jordan which means which is the same
you know what you know what pisses me
off about it actually it's not so much
that like you know if you guys want to
go that's fine right like if you want to
make a circus of this
that's on you
however I'm gonna get I'm almost gonna
guarantee that you know just like George
Santos and Marjorie Taylor green which
were the two people that showed up for
for Donald Trump's uh indictment day
I would almost go out on a limb and and
assume that Jim Jordan and whoever else
decides to show up during this
field trip is using constituent taxpayer
money to fly there right to go there to
expense it I I had to go out to the
stake dinner I had to get my my TomTom
filled up before I went out and had my
little tantrum well hey they want to
make sure to take advantage of all the
amenities that are that are provided in
such a libtard city like New York I mean
they really want to take their time like
the crimes you do see the people it's
like why they're sitting on the
sidewalk on a Sidewalk Cafe right but
also like you have Marjorie Taylor green
who and moans about how New York
City is crime ridden you went to another
state and city that you don't represent
and had an unsanctioned protest rally
about a dude who committed a crime
and it's and the local in the Manhattan
D.A is following you know Law and Order
and you're you're you're upset about it
that people came out and said oh you
know what you and Donald Trump
First Amendment right you have the First
Amendment right to go out and say
it was unsanctioned but whatever but
also these people who live there in New
York and actually experience the
that Donald Trump did and have to live
with that right they they are just as as
worthy and privileged to and there's to
use their voice and say go yourself
right right well and they will exactly
say that those exact words go
yourself you know the other thing too
um because last week now we had Senator
Doug Jones on yeah um to talk about
having the Democratic National
Convention in Atlanta now the Democratic
National uh convention has decided to
have it in Chicago but I noticed as soon
as that happened they're like not only
New York City but they're like Chicago's
a hell hole yeah oh my God so so there
listen I'm telling you I'm gonna say
this out loud right now it's April 17th
Monday
uh 1 28 p.m eastern time you can mark
the time stamp I'm telling you
because the Democratic National
Convention is in Chicago Chicago is
going to be the most crime-ridden city
oh yeah on the planet and you were I
think were you in that space last night
um I was listening to it a little bit
Yeah I listened to I spoke
yeah early on I spoke for a minute and
then I kind of just like why wouldn't
this one of Mario's Twitter spaces yeah
and almost the entire space because I
think the thing was Walmart in Chicago
we kind of talked about it um yesterday
or I mean on Friday I believe no no no
no no yeah yesterday yesterday yeah yeah
it was on it was on your patreon
um so we're just talking about that a
little bit but when I got into the room
like they weren't even talking they
weren't even talking about Chicago
anymore it was it was the white people
in the room claiming that there's no
white privilege and there's no
systematic racism like it turned into
that quick and it's like I wonder what
about the debate about the city of
Chicago turned this into a systematic
racism do you want to know the
progression of that conversation yeah
sure so I came in early on and I I said
it I said my my two cents which was
about charter school so you were talking
about Chicago yeah so it started with
Chicago right it was like oh crime in
Chicago like how do we prevent this like
what's going on what are the causes blah
blah blah right because they wanted to
blame that on the right exactly they
wanted to say you know for various
different reasons
and so I went in and I was like look
charter schools are are right they
they sign a contract with the state uh
they're publicly funded and they siphon
funds off that should be going to the
the public high schools the public grade
schools whatever it might be
and uh
and and the charter school also has and
this is actually something I wanted to
bring up with Jess because she brought
it up about public schools and like how
they're four out of five days in
Missouri
um but in
in these Charter Schools they can decide
they're like oh yeah everyone everyone
we want the best education for the
students but they can at will like a
job employer decide you know
what this kid just isn't up to our
standards and the reason being is
because they are very much test driven
and results driven to say like how are
we doing how are we performing are we
doing better than the public institution
that's in the state can we get more
funding they need those numbers to prove
validity right and we've gone from a
place where public education was
something that we were great like we
were you know up there in the list of
terms of like education that we offered
to our
younger generation right but since then
you have the privatization of of school
system and education you have funds that
are being siphoned off from public
schools you have resources you have the
defunding of libraries and other sort of
resources that can and should be used
for education and then Republicans go
well what do you expect like what's
going on what's all this crime what's
going it's like well you know if you if
you create a system of failure then
those people are going to rely on other
things if you don't create a an economic
uh uh uh area right that can sustain
itself that that allows for
um Regular People to have a job to
support their family or open a business
then what do you expect is going to
happen right the same reason that you
saw people being like well I wasn't
given any money during covid there's an
incentive there to then take an action
that you might not normally take which
is you might steal something or you
might take something not pay for
something whatever it is because like
I got a baby at home I got a family
at home I gotta pay them right and then
and then Republicans get all upset and
be like well look at what they're doing
well look at the conditions in which you
created right food deserts crime area
low income like not offering opportunity
right and so it basically went down that
path from that to education and then it
was brought into this argument which I
sent you the link I was like there's
this woman in here Jennifer who always
let's describe who she she's the one who
who is out to
um kill SEL which is
um um um social emotional learning in
school so so there's social emotional
learning CRT there's uh some other
there's some other all these scary scary
things which by the way her Theory she
has this conspiracy theory that when
when Obama came in into presidency into
the office
he implemented a new program and that
new program caused the widespread
destruction of the education system like
basically overnight so there was a there
was a there was a guy in the room last
night Jay mall he ran for Jamal Green he
ran for mayor of Chicago in this past
the past two elections and if you read
up on Jamal Green he actually has a
pretty cool backstory which is you know
he identified that chase JP Morgan Chase
was not offering
um yeah I think it was seven years ago
he had this lawsuit right here this
lawsuit it wasn't he wasn't on they
weren't they weren't actually they were
choosing white people over black people
because he was like black for every
dollar it was like 2.4 cents or
something like that so he identified
he's like look there's this systematic
oppression and racism that's happening
it's built in everything right to deny
that and the room was blowing up over it
so that's and that's where it went so so
like Jamal Green won this won this case
against uh JP Morgan Chase to prove that
they weren't giving money to the black
or brown communities and they were
giving it to White and he found out he's
like the default rate of these loans
were the same on the North side right
and on the South Side so you came in I
came in after he had given all the facts
so that you know what we should do we
should invite him on the show yeah yeah
um yeah reach out to him and let's
invite him on the show to see if he can
break that down for us and how that
worked because I'm telling you folks
they're gonna go after Chicago they're
going to pen it up as oh it's crime
ridden I wouldn't be surprised I would
not be surprised if Jim Jordan takes his
stupid little field trip to Chicago even
um to try to act like you know the city
that Democrats chose was crime and
that's why they chose it but but I want
to show you Gabe Sanchez
how people reacted to this Committee
hearing this morning there's a video
from inside and people were and people
were using their First Amendment right
now this listen this is very important
because loud noises
are Fascist Kryptonite okay so it melts
down pretty quickly in this room but I'm
also going to show you some of the
opening statements from representative
Nadler who who represents part of New
York
um also but this is this is how this is
how it started and how it was going uh
for Jim I don't report sex Jordan watch
this little clip one video with their
face with no attention Donald J Trump
hello
friends please
thank you
so it sounds like a pussy-ass that
was triggered because Donald Trump is
getting has been indicted by Alvin Bragg
right I mean they're they're they're
coming after him being like Alvin Bragg
run on ran on this idea of coming after
Trump no if you look at the okay look at
the tape you know uh if you if you look
at the video of of what Trump released
which is every time that Alvin Bragg
brought was asked about or brought up
Donald Trump right because he's like
look
uh I have exp what he said in the videos
was I have experience going after Trump
and the Trump organization so if that if
that is going to be if I am going to do
that I have the most experience for it
he never said like oh I promise I
guarantee I'm gonna I'm gonna come after
Trump and indict him he literally was
asked the question
that New Yorkers wondered about which is
Donald Trump hey are you going to go out
are you going to go there because he's a
criminal and he's getting away with this
if no one else no one else in
Manhattan would get away with that but
that so exactly do
something so he's like if I do like I
can tell you of all the candidates
running for Manhattan D.A which again is
a publicly elected office which you know
New York or or rather Republicans uh
don't understand well they hate
democracy well they just don't
understand how elections work right
if you point that person and say they
should be the you know whoever in office
that's who should they be anyway in
these videos Alvin Bragg's like look man
I have the most experience I've done
over a hundred like prosecutions
whatever I've gone after the the Trump
organization uh case I I led that one
um it's just like this is a guy who has
experience and when asked about it he
goes well I have the most experience
with it I'm not going to promise you I'm
gonna take this guy to jail but
if we find a crime well yeah he's got it
he's got to get an indictment he has to
bring it to court others right you gotta
prosecute it in front of a jury and the
jury has to decide and they get the
final decision not only that he brought
the charges in front of a grand jury
which they decided not him they decided
on the 34 felony counts now uh Jerry
Nadler had some opening statements now
apparently I'm don't know if C-SPAN was
actually airing this I guess they did
want to go air because they don't
because C-SPAN is like we're not
equipped to go do your stupid
field trips right if you want to have
committee hearings we'll produce
those things right here in Washington we
got rooms we got everything set up
you're costing us all kinds of
money to do this stupid elsewhere
um and have to have these these stupid
ass fraudulent hearings that you're
doing but here is um Newsmax was
carrying it though Gabe Sanchez of
course Trader TV News Network was
covering it I mean why not you got to go
there where the action is you got to
prove minor reports sex crimes Jordan
trying to trying to obstruct a criminal
investigation into their Republican
orange Jesus but here's Jerry nadler's
view of his statements
um in the opening here we go let me be
very clear we are here today in lower
Manhattan for one reason and one reason
only the chairman is doing the bidding
of Donald Trump
committee Republic has designed this
hearing to intimidate and deter the duly
elected district attorney of Manhattan
from doing the work as constituents
elected him to do
they have demanded access to the
inworkings of an ongoing criminal case
information to which they know they are
not entitled
they have subpoenaed a witness who used
to work for the district attorney whom
they know cannot answer their questions
and they have earned a lawsuit that
risks future Congressional oversight as
a result
they have perpetuated the anti-semitic
and racist tropes that Mr Trump has
directed at both the prosecutor and the
judge in this case
they are using their public offices and
the resources of this committee to
protect their political Patron Donald
Trump okay so he goes on to talk more
about um you know why the Republicans
but it's obvious Gabe Sanchez listen I
cannot believe
that the the sheep of Donald
Trump who keeps posting in all caps on
social it's all political it's a
political Witch Hunt and here they are
packing up to go do a political Witch
Hunt on a Manhattan D.A in his policies
in New York City which they have no
jurisdiction over none not a
single shred of it do they have jerseys
isn't that the Republican way you caused
a bunch of Riff Raff and you say oh
there's this problem and then you have
all his fake outrage and then you don't
actually have a solution and so you
waste a lot of time and money especially
in a city state uh that you don't
represent and you don't have
jurisdiction right and so if you
and moan like a ass right so
you're not gonna actually be able you're
not gonna do anything you're you have
you have the right to say stuff
uh I mean I'd be careful with what you
say because you're going to get into an
area of your crimes yeah well you're
going to give away your crime yeah give
away the crimes defamation there's all
these things but yeah you look at
Republicans like oh look I mean like
it's all distraction right like just
brought it just just brought it up
earlier 34 which is found over Mr Mister
on YouTube says 30 with 34 witches
already found listen so this is a good
point and I will get back to Jess what
you said this is a good point is that
look everything's political but the main
argument for Republicans about these
charges that were brought against Trump
every single one of them I heard like
always came back dude this is political
they're making it political that's why
this is flimsy that's why this is not
going to work that's why he's gonna
Propel to the White House I mean in
these Twitter spaces it was time after
time and time again the argument was
this is political what course it is he's
running for president the whole
point is he was using his business and
protestantly making business
transactions to help his campaign to run
for president right almost every single
investigation in Grand Jury is
into the politics of it so yeah it's
political but but I think it's great
when Republicans they they say oh it's
all political so we're gonna go do
politics in New York City and we're
gonna we're gonna up in the Judiciary
Committee which is a political Committee
in the in a political uh institution
like the House of Representatives where
politicians are elected by political
means to go to New York City and have a
political hearing yeah it's it's like so
it's political so then you go and you go
balls deep into the problem so I mean
this cell that they're having it's gonna
be a tough sell man this is a tough sell
and I understand that Jim Jordan is
doing everything he can by the direction
of Donald Trump to obstruct that's just
my assumption and I would imagine that
Alvin Braggs eventually going to get
evidence of it and Jim Jordan's going to
be here I hope so I mean I I I
welcome Jim Jordan to obstruct in this
case I I hope that Jim Jordan
around and finds out with Alvin Bragg I
don't think Jim Jordan understands it
just because you're from Ohio Iowa and
you live in Washington DC if you
obstruct in a investigation and
Manhattan DA's office they have
jurisdiction to charge your ass
with obstruction dumbass no matter where
you do it at so good luck to Jim Jordan
when he's around and find out
what were you going to say about what
what just oh I was just going to say
about you know Jess brought something up
and I wanted to highlight it is she was
talking about how like you know these
these Representatives can't be bothered
to actually help their area right they
can't be bothered to help the roads or
the schools or the jobs or whatever it
might be these Republicans it's all a
distraction right and um
and uh ride four brings it up he says
yeah Gabe gkp is the straw man party and
that's what they are right it's a bunch
of distraction and a bunch of a bunch of
Republicans trying to create a straw man
argument and say oh this is the problem
and uh at the same time they will
you know blame something else or they'll
they'll say look over here but not over
here kind of thing like it's just that's
that's all that it is and so this this
field trip to to New York City is just
one more uh piece of that kind of
gqp uh chaos puzzle which is if we
distract you enough and make it seem
like we're doing our job right because
they're like look we held this hearing
who went to D we went to New York City
even though their position as
Congressman or in this committee has no
jurisdiction in New York they're just
it's Fanfare for the gqp cult
right they're like oh yeah they're
holding them accountable well nothing's
ever going to come out of this no if
anything again there's gonna be
obstruction crimes defamation there's
all these things that you're going
you're attacking that's the only thing
that's ever going to come out of it is
is that it's possible Jim Jordan if he's
doing this the direction of Donald Trump
to to stifle the the criminal
charges and the craziest part is Jim
Jordan's idea of obstruction was hey
let's go to the actual jurisdiction of
Alvin Bragg like let's sit in his
jurisdiction and and obstruct his
criminal investigation and Donald Trump
that would be fantastic for me to prove
that I'm doing obstruction inside his
jurisdiction like you dumb and the best
part like Alvin Bragg's like look man
I'm not gonna this case up like
there's no reason for me to mess this up
so what I am going to do is I'm going to
respond to these claims that New York
City is not safe by tweeting out a
infographic warning you
warning you that if you continue down
this path I will do something and then
of course he did he filed a lawsuit
against Jordan and this committee be
like stop with my well and
I think I think this civil lawsuit
um that Alvin Bragg has put on Jim
Jordan and the Judiciary Committee is a
soft warning that if I find obstruction
because if Alvin Bragg finds obstruction
in this lawsuit he will bring charges I
believe he will bring charges against
Donald Trump and Jim Jordan anyone else
who's coordinating for the abstraction
of these of these criminal indictments
so good luck to you Jim Jordan keep
around speaking of another
bonehead that's been around and
finding out speaking of morons elected
to congress not to be Congress people
but to be social media vile
influencers uh Lauren bovard giving away
the game here I want to show this clip
because I think it's so important
because they're they're desperate folks
for 2024 they're desperate to sell that
you're not a democracy like and this is
the worst part honestly this is the
worst possible narrative that
Republicans can start to have is that
you're not a democracy you're not a
democracy it doesn't count when you vote
keep keep doing that dummy keep doing
that they're they're so they're going to
suppress their own vote here I and and
this is yeah I mean like it's it reminds
me of uh of
uh
[Music]
uh Lynn wood in Georgia last in 2020 he
was like don't go vote don't go vote
yeah all right yeah don't go vote yeah
yeah don't don't complain when nobody
votes for you you told them don't go
vote right whatever I mean this this
again is professional rake stepping at
its best and here it is with Lauren
bobert one of the best rake steppers in
Congress again someone said it the other
day in the chat let her eat rake let's
do it so maybe one of the things that we
need to address with the Democrat
parties you played a clip from the
teachers union uh with Randy there
talking uh maybe one thing we need to
address is we're not a democracy so with
that maybe maybe that's where you're
getting it wrong is saying that we are a
democracy we are a constitutional
republic
what a dumbass
they love saying that they're like
a democracy
like like dude go look up what
the word it's constitutional republic is
what a constitutional republic is it'll
say it's a it's a type of Demi like this
is so stupid she's the same person who
said that the constitution was not a
living document I'm sorry what do you
call amendments then well this is
associated a document that's living
means that it's organic and it's
changing it's right you did right
amendments it doesn't have roots in the
ground and it's not got leaves it came
from a goddamn tree Tony that's true
that is true well I you know as she can
probably neither confirm nor deny that
here's the thing this
constitutional republic thing that we're
not a democracy this is going to
suppress their vote folks and we should
encourage them to keep saying this
stupid to to people in this country
because it is the dumbest
argument I have ever heard that not only
are we not a democracy democracy bad
like whoa what what no yeah like what
are you talking about like try that try
to sell that on the street corner
that democracy is bad that the voice of
the people is back get the out of
here that is the dumbest that is the
dumbest position I think we're at in
this stupid timeline of where
we're at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life is that
they're like yeah democracy bad and
we're gonna run on that like okay go
ahead not even like Hey
we're not a democracy but we should
strive and work to become a democracy
like if you're making the argument that
we're not a democracy like we're not a
pure 100 democracy and you want to make
it that that's a bit of a different
argument right but I I could understand
that they're like we're not this but we
want to make it this well but that's how
they tried to frame it in the past right
because she's on if you look here she's
on Charlie yeah right she's on Charlie
Kirk so Charlie Kirk always makes this
argument that look we're not a hundred
percent a democracy we're actually a
constitutional like he's tried to form
that argument right that's not what
Lauren bobert is saying in this clip and
you can hear him you can hear him be
like yes yeah yes yes she's saying we
are not a democracy at all all and
because democracy is bad that's what
she's saying Republic good democracy bad
like you dumbass okay let me let
me break it down for you Bobo
there is automobiles okay and there are
brands of automobiles like a Buick now
in the brand of Buick there are
different models of the Buick one of
them maybe being a Regal or a LeSabre
let's say so there are systems of
government which are the automobiles you
stupid and then there are
democracies which are the Buick are you
still following you idiot now
inside that democracy which is the Buick
we have different models of democracy
like the Regal and the LeSabre here in
this country you stupid ass
we have the model of a constitutional
representative Republic you stupid
so follow the bouncing ball you dummy
and realize that that a constitutional
republic is a type of democracy Jesus
this is these are not
complicated ideas and you know what
honestly this type of rake stepping
again let her eat rake here and let them
keep eating this rake because this idea
that they're going to try to sell to the
American people that democracy bad
Republic good is beautiful
because when we get to 2024 folks the
general election your choices are going
to be democracy or autocracy that's
going to be your choice so when these
when people like Lauren bobert and these
Maga Republicans go to their
constituents and their their people who
they have influence over and they're
like democracy bad democracy bad and
then we get to the choice of autocracy
versus democracy that choice is going to
be Stark and let me tell you something
when we get to that moment and that in
this timeline I believe that it's the
only thing that's going to cure this
disease of absolute Maga
stupidity yeah because just to have them
rejected all around the country so yeah
what do you get someone your message of
democracy bag Lauren bobert it's uh I
mean I think they've come to a point
where
you know they they they have to commit
to certain things I mean we've seen them
I mean even again you know we talked
about this yesterday during the weekend
Roundup and it was like you've seen them
try to go after the gay community you've
seen them try to go after this and now
they're going after the trans community
and each time they do that like women's
rights right these are things that have
backfired because they're not popular
things to attack right you have a small
group of people a bunch of
very fragile ego white men who believe
that they're speaking for the majority
of Americans and as time goes on and
people are educated and people live
through those experiences
they go ah actually wait hold on why why
are we doing this why why are we
attacking this group why are we taking
these rights away this doesn't feel like
us I mean
to give you a prime example a
top billionaire donor and his friends
are now going to Halt any donations that
are going to uh to Ron desantis's
presidential campaign because of his
extremist social policies so you've got
Donald Trump and Ron DeSantis trying to
push these extreme policies and intense
attacks against each other and they go
oh uh we we need to take away these
rights and we need to ban that and we
need to say you can't do this and some
Republicans with who are very
influential and their friends are going
um actually
um nope no that's a little that's a
little like we'll take away those things
or like these other things but we won't
attack women's rights and we won't uh
ban books like that seems a little crazy
guys it almost seems like we're going
back to a certain period in time when we
attacked fascists for doing that right
so at least there are I mean again I
don't agree with all Republicans on this
stuff but like
at least there are some Republicans that
are having some
seen the light moment and they're like
uh what are you doing I'm not giving you
any money if you're gonna do this why
would love I would love to show you the
clip of um Nancy mace I think is her
name over the weekend but I got another
rake stepping video she's another one
who who goes after people and like she's
not great but she attacks other people
she makes fun of Margaret Taylor
green Lauren bobert uh Matt Gates it's
funny it's funny to see I've got a clip
for her I've got a clip for her here
with Marjorie Taylor green and then can
you pull that um clip of her talking
about gun reform and Republicans need to
get on board
um no no no no no no and Nancy Nancy
mace the uh the Republican congresswoman
from South Carolina so this is here's
another rake stepping
um that that the Republicans are doing
and they're continuing to doing this
Lindsey Graham tried to push back on
this stupid the other day because
even Lindsey Graham's like look this is
not a good look that you guys
are supporting some someone who
divulged classified documents on a
Discord server because they got their
feelings hurt because they
wanted to show that they know more about
classified information than someone on
the Discord server but let's listen to
Marjorie Taylor green and Steve bannon's
framing of of treason and terrorists in
this country
um referring to John Brennan now no one
knows John Brennan was the uh was the
CIA director During the period where
Donald Trump was the interim uh he was
the uh a president-elect so John Brennan
was the um the CIA director then listen
to this crazy John Brennan
converted to Islam the the same religion
the rumor what and and you heard Steve
Bannon go the rumor what the I was
just like he's he's now he's now a
Muslim I don't know where that came from
I have no idea but let's continue with
this this I mean she starts off on the
wrong foot but let's listen
Chief in uh in Saudi Arabia
right that's pretty interesting uh you
know as we're a country that was they
declared Jihad on us on 9 11. and John
Brennan are these the same Saudis that
Jared Kushner and Donald Trump and Elon
Musk hang out with us those the ones
they talking about that that said Jihad
on America hmm I wonder if I wonder if
these two have any kind of feelings
about Donald Trump
um I don't know doing golf tournaments
at his golf courses with these Saudis
who declared uh Jihad on America I don't
know I'm just it's just a question I'd
ask but let's let's see what she says
anything about that has orchestrated uh
more damage through being a former when
he was director of the CIA you're not a
fan of his term as CIA director
absolutely not any any man that will
sign his name and get 51 members of the
intelligence do you think John Brenner
is in back of the the cover-up of the
laptop from Hell the week before the
election 100 51 members more of the
hunter Biden laptop Dogg oh my God these
people just never let it go but
listen to what she says about
underbody's laptop listen I'm telling
you what we're saying us yelling and
screaming I know it feels like sometime
it doesn't work but listen to what she
says or is that the intelligence
Community sign their name you sign your
name to truth you don't sign your name
to a lie they signed their name to a lie
to completely stop president Trump from
winning the 2020 election John Solomon's
going to be on here at 11. John
Solomon's saying he's hearing from the
investigation that's going on that
people are actually talking about how
politically motivated was and they knew
it was alive we know it's a lie we
absolutely know it's a lie we know
Hunter Biden's laptop is real everyone
knows Hunter Biden's laptop is real I'll
go further on John Brennan John there
you go 100 by 9 top is real when we say
it's fake and it's all and it
doesn't exist it's ringing true to them
they're getting scared that that is
working that messaging is working folks
because it's the truth it's the truth
and and they're doing they're doing more
projecting here in this oh yeah what's
funny is she she's complaining about 51
intelligent agencies signing a letter to
to take away the election from Donald
Trump John Brennan was not the CIA
director during 20 the 2020 election you
stupid I I have to call two
of them yeah I know our I know our
folks in Australia it doesn't offend
them but and I know our folks in the
audience when I apply that name to
certain folks like Gilbert and green
they don't get offended but but listen
it just it's a crazy but the thing is is
they're telling on themselves here Gabe
Sanchez because Marjorie Taylor green is
saying hey we hear the arguments about
about
um about Hunter Biden's laptop and we're
scared that we're losing those that
messaging she's terrified because she's
like it is real it is real yeah I mean
if you have to if she has to go there in
this you gotta remember she's on Steve
bannon's show which almost every single
person on Steve Bannon show should
believe at this point if they believe
the if they're sheep and they're Maga
and they're believing all the delusion
they should believe that the laptop from
Hell exists but she has to confirm it to
them over and over which means our
messaging is working
um is this the clip from uh from Nancy
Grace I mean excuse me Nancy mace Nancy
mace not to be confused with Nancy Grace
uh Nancy Grace is another
box but you know what who's counting
right okay let's see this is um this is
on oh this is on Fox News I thought it
was on CNN but it's on Fox News which is
even better here
um let's take a listen to how she is
scared that Republicans the plot line is
slipping away because I think that's
what bobert and Marjorie Taylor green
don't understand that the plot is
slipping away from them but let's listen
to Nancy Mason and Republicans can no
longer be silent on this issue and it's
not about the Second Amendment there are
plenty of things that we can be doing
besides offering prayers and silence
some sort of amber alert for example to
let the community know there's been a
shooting strengthening our background
checks is something that the vast
majority of Americans support hardening
our schools churches and synagogues okay
so I don't agree with her on almost any
of this I don't think that red flag logs
go far enough background checks are
certainly not enough to stop the gun
violence that we have right now she's
talking about some kind of Amber Alert
system as if that's going to cause like
oh yeah that's a great idea just let
everyone know how many mass shootings
are in their area like yeah that's gonna
solve the problem of mass shootings I
mean to make them more aware and maybe
they'll be more active in gun
and making their legislators do gun
safety reform yeah and then she talks
about hardening schools listen to this
line that she uses here Gabe Sanchez
you're going to hear these words more
and more listen so that there is
deterrence so that when a shooter
potential Mass shooter enters a place
that they know that maybe they're not
going to make it through because there's
bulletproof doors bulletproof windows
what the so we gotta bulletproof
everything in schools and hospitals and
Banks and church you people are some
dumb we can't even afford
you can't even afford to fix
roads and give people Mental Health Care
get the out of here with this
nonsense but listen to what she says
here about Republicans because this is a
sign folks this is a sign that they know
from what has happened in Tennessee in
the last few weeks that they must get on
board of doing something even Bill Lee
knew it when he signed that that law
let's listen
uh you know those kinds of Common Sense
things are all things that every
American on either side of the aisle can
get behind but yet every time there's a
mass shooting and they're increasing
every year every week we just we don't
say anything want to bury our heads in
the sand and hope that it goes away but
guess what it's not going away and
that's exactly the point and that's why
she's ringing the alarm bells to the GOP
the gqp and say hey hey
something's gonna happen and we're gonna
we're gonna be the butt of the joke
because we're not involved in the
negotiations because I mean Elton Elton
Fulcher on Facebook says you know we
have amber alerts in Virginia kids are
still getting shot right exactly because
the Amber Alert the Amber Alert doesn't
stop someone from getting a gun it it
only is like hey hey by the way if you
didn't know there's a school across town
stay away from there because there's
children being slaughtered in there with
a gun because you won't hold your
representatives accountable and you're
Representatives won't protect you in the
way of legislation to make sure that the
psychopath across town that right now is
murdering children is in the school like
right why what the it's like it's
like when when uh when when Republicans
tried to make the argument that police
officers stop crime it's like no they
don't stop crime because they're not
Batman the crime doesn't happen
and then they're like jump through your
door or your kitchen window and then
like stop the assailant right one it's
not Minority Report either they can't
stop crying before it happens
yeah and as police like again they're
not Batman they're also not legally
responsible for the you know uh
for risking their own life to protect
you we we've seen that legally in court
right in a case they are not
responsible for actually protecting you
but it's a ton I do have I uh actually I
do have something
I have something I have something from
anonymous
oh really this is new yeah there looks
like looks like
the little uh the Epstein black book the
uh oh let me guess whose name is in it
let me guess
let me guess whose name is in the new
Blacklist I wonder who it could be and
I'm I'm and I wonder if it could be more
than once probably I'm guessing is what
you're gonna show me yeah it's uh it's
definitely when was this release this
was at least um I don't know release a
while back but Anonymous no that was
redacted though this one is unredacted
or at least this one's coming up as
unredacted as being released the first
time right now
um so
if I here's actually you know what we
will play a video which I haven't played
yet but
um we'll summarize what's going on
which which which pager you want me to
show here so if you go to I went to the
link you had 85 page 85
um God damn he's digging on a
page there's a ton of people in there
you got David Blaine in there you got
all sorts of 85 Houston page 85 you got
Ivanka Trump you got Ivana Trump on
there whoa whoa what yeah
okay 85 uh-oh uh oh oh no
Donald Trump was like I didn't really
hang out with the guy much I don't
really know sure didn't look here Donald
Trump the Trump organization 7-2 and
Fifth Avenue Hey look it's got phone
numbers it's kind of Hey Hey
look it's got a AOL email are
you me what the oh home
home Spa ooh uh Howard Wilson he's the
house man
look the Mar-A-Lago number look the
Trump security oh my God Melania Melania
phone whoa it seems as if it seems as if
Donald Trump
um had a spot in Jeffrey Epstein's book
here I'm just yeah
I you know I wonder I wonder if there is
uh some former other former presidents
that ended up in this book all right can
you can you find the Obama name Shirley
it's in there
uh Obama Obama Obama you can find Obama
look for it I don't know if I'll find it
see if you can find that
um oh yeah no nothing no oh man nah and
when you know it damn I mean you would
think a pedophile ring baby demonic
right Satanic ritual
would do it right you'd think that
somebody who was eating babies right the
Demonic cake like Barack Obama like
Barack Obama Roger Taylor green would
say that you would think that Barack
Obama and Hillary Clinton and the rest
of the uh Democratic party would be in
here but I'm not seeing Barack Obama
That's suspicious you know what I mean
it just it feels like maybe maybe just
maybe the people that are in this book
right are in the book for a reason and
the people who aren't in the book
probably aren't there
for a reason
oh my God but O'Donnell O'Neal Oates
this this highly interesting so who who
who released this you said this is
anonymous anonymous put this because
then I sent you I sent you a link with a
video there's a tick tocker that that
goes into it so I haven't watched that
video yet but I was sent to it actually
Dara sent it to me uh she sent the the
PDF and she wanted to show it is she in
the chat yeah no she was talking okay
but she sent me a video as well this
Tick Tock and so I wanted a I wanted to
play it to give context here if you're
wondering why they want to ban Tick Tock
here might be a reason yeah stop
scrolling now I told you they were no
longer holding back and they want to
make sure that we have a huge piece of
information
and that's Jeffrey Epstein's little
black book
no yes it was made public by a court
order but it was very hard to find and
heavily suppressed Anonymous is making
sure that we had both the redacted and
unredacted versions
now it's 96 pages but I'm going to show
you the best ones in my opinion for
multiple cities he has massage and in
the city's name and then a bunch of
females names
you all know how massages tie into this
Peter Soros
good old Rupert oh
Kevin
if anybody have any doubt
there's good old Donnie
and Trump was on the jet six four times
than previously known
neither the clintons or the Obamas were
in that book
God damn
God damn you're huge oh the laptop from
hell right oh man the little black go
get that wouldn't die the little black
book that could oh my god
oh man I think I can I think again I
think I can tell the truth oh
God damn I tell you what these
scumbags never fails never fails with
these scumbags um thank you for
Dara for sending that to Gabe so we
could uh play that on the very end of
the show I appreciate it a lot uh if
you're not in the chat send her my love
if you would we'll do we'll do we've got
the little black book from hell I mean
it is like that's there's anything that
comes from that place it's the things
that Jeffrey Epstein did and I'm not I'm
not
I'm not um I'm not saying we just uh
posted the um the unredacted version of
Donald Trump's listing but we may have
so you might want to rewind it yeah you
may have shown the unredacted version
and you can also find the unredacted
version online as well yes well here we
go Robert Smith already
Robert Smith already put it in there
Jeffrey little black book unredacted
uh-oh uh oh there it is we didn't give
you the link
yeah I what am I supposed to do yeah
what am I supposed to do what am I
supposed to and and do not do not go
listen to me do not go to that link and
go to page 85 and take a screenshot and
post it on social media don't do that
that is a thing you should not be doing
that that would probably don't go to the
other pages in the book and take
screenshots of exactly
Trump or anyone else man that would
really piss them off if you did that so
please don't do that
I'm telling you right now don't do it
oh God I'm glad we went over time for
that that was working that was worth it
I I'm telling you I'm telling you
someone sent us let me see if I can find
that someone sent us a meme
um
last week because we talked about
professional rake stepping and then oh
yeah it was Joy Leaf was it yeah let the
meat rake yeah um let me see if I can uh
find that back I know I thought it was
great because you sent it to me and I
was like oh yeah it's great this warms
my heart I'm glad that that people are
taking what we say and turn it into
content that cannot be
destroyed you know that's right
um so here is let me see if I can find
it because they are professional rake
steppers and we should not stand in
their way as they want to step on these
rakes over and over and over again
please please stand on these rakes and
walk on them and and don't take the
shovel out of their hands there's a
tweet she sent
um she says I made this for y'all feel
free to label the rakes
with any of their numerous missteps uh
so if you want you can go grab her
version yeah make your own version
anything on there going after trans
right people going after the game black
book whatever you want black book
whatever you want you know uh that
laptop
yeah anything supporting the supporting
the the Army National Guardsmen who
divulge Secrets who put our our our our
fighting women men and women men and
women at risk
um that maybe maybe Trump keeping to
obstruct these these uh these hearing
are these these criminal investigations
into himself by threatening these
prosecutors maybe that's a rake step
Ronda santis
um Jesus Christ you can actually label
this guy Ron DeSantis instead of
Republicans and you could fill all these
rakes with rakes that he's stepping on
like Disney like oh we're anti whoa
we're we're woke Goes To Die the
abortion ban that he just signed in
Florida
there's all kinds uh someone says link
link to us you know what um here's what
I'll do I'll I'll say this the link is
in the comments okay and I'll I'll also
I'll pull it and I'll put it um I'll put
it on my patreon and I'll put it on
Twitter and I'll put it on Facebook and
the YouTube channel so you guys can go
screenshot it or grab it and you can you
can edit it at your at your leisure and
post it on social media so thank you Joy
leave and I'm for giving that's great
piece of art it'll turn out great we
know it will we know it will and thank
you for joining us again every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific here on
YouTube Twitter and twitch do not forget
to subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast someone keeps reminding me that
it's a hat week it's going to be hat
week starting tomorrow so don't forget
tomorrow hat week starts them hat
week starts tomorrow so we'll start that
tomorrow also follow us on Twitter at
Tony Michaels POD at the Tony Michaels
and I am Gabe Sanchez you can find Joy
Leafs uh meme there on our timeline also
download every single episode on Apple's
Spotify and Google it's free to download
every single episode free 99. y'all five
finger discount on the show on Facebook
if you still have an account just go to
Tony Michaels and receive your five
finger discount of the two hour show
every single day over there on Facebook
I gotta I got a quick update here do the
twitch I got a quick update though if
you got a Prime account go ahead and
link your Amazon Prime account to Twitch
we also get a few dollars of Amazon's
money when you do that and it's free to
you because if you have Amazon Prime you
get one free subscription on Twitch if
you link your Amazon Prime account to
Twitch and give us that free
subscription we get a couple bucks each
month here's the thing you have to renew
it every single month so make sure if
you've done it before that you go back
in and renew it that way we get our
extra money because Amazon is not gonna
make it easy you just gotta go once
every month renew the subscription we
get a couple bucks what was your update
well the update was it turns out that
you know Elon Musk Twitter uh they they
suspended the anonymous Ops United
account after it was released I wonder I
wonder if it's because all elon's Pals
and buddies are in that yeah and they
said so they really they opened up a new
account and they said this is what upset
Elon Anonymous releasing Epstein's
flight logs and the unredacted little
black book was approving your meetings
with Epstein happened oh
wait you mean you mean there's a name
that is is resembles Elon musk's name in
that book uh-oh yeah
I haven't gone through to find it but it
seems that seems crazy not surprising uh
at all at all that Elon Musk would do
then so everybody maybe we'll follow
this Anonymous story as the week's uh
tick on here and you're going to want to
follow us every single weekday Monday
through Friday You're Not Gonna Want to
Miss a show for two hours every single
day noon Eastern
11 Central nine Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch simulcasting from
Facebook until tomorrow same time same
place Surf's Up you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
them em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn head ass Beacon